Alberto what's up buddy
hey Rich can you hear me yeah what's
going on
awesome um not much thank you for doing
this I uh really looking forward asking
I've been having these problems since
high school where women for some reason
think that I'm gay
um
I had several experiences where you know
I was going out with this chick and then
when I made a move she freaking jumped
out and she says like I thought you were
gay
friend zone with her
no not at all I just uh stop talking to
her how many um I don't like how many
how many official dates did you go on
before you made a move on her
ah probably three
I mean I slept I slept with her same
room same bed she told me in the morning
that I had a you know hard wood and I
told her it was normal for guys to wake
up like that but uh it's more of a
friends of my mom I was in I was 16. I
was just stay over until I decided to
make a move I wasn't really interested
until she started telling me that she
always wanted to have a somebody like me
I guess I thought I thought
she liked me that's why I made a move
but I usually don't chase I usually
don't chase girls I I don't like to
waste my time too much where do you live
I have more I live in Arizona
in your Latin you're from Mexico or
yes I was born in Mexico I came over to
the states when I was in Middle School
do you want to throw your camera on so
we can get a look at your butt or there
you go okay we're a good looking guy
right
yeah
it's maybe something to do with your
voice and your tonality because I mean
like just listen in your voice when
we're when we're chatting I mean it
sounds a little uh finocchio is what the
Italians would call it
write that down
all right do you think that might be
because of a low testosterone levels do
you have low T levels
I never checked my uh T levels
you got a decent beard I mean like most
of the time when guys have facial hair
if they have low T it's very patchy
right like it doesn't fill in I can see
that you're you know you got a decent
beard I mean like look you can deepen
your voice you know doing voice
exercises you can increase your
testosterone levels marginally by taking
certain supplements like in my
supplement line if you go to the
unpluggedalpha.com and then sort sort by
testosterone support
zinc vitamin DK and the T support those
three alone will probably boost your
testosterone a couple hundred points
you're going to need to lift weights and
rest though right like that's the other
key thing as well but usually women well
see a guy as gay if I mean if you're
straight and if they see you as gay or
they say Oh I thought that you were gay
it's usually because your mannerisms and
behavior and your dress and your style
and the way that you approach them is
more like friend zoning right whereas
you know like a straight guy will make
his intention very clear right away
right yes exactly when you sit down at
her house and she's like hey Alberto you
know can I get you a drink and she's
going to the kitchen you look at it and
you go actually I like to wear that ass
as a hat oh sorry did I just say that
that's what an alpha male will say right
to express his intentions and you know
say what he's thinking but if you play
the friend zone guy for like two three
dates and then you make a move but
you're like
slow with it but you're still very nice
and buoyant and stuff like that she
might put you in like that hey this guy
could be in the gay Zone sort of thing
right
yeah and I'm more concerned with uh
like as a moment encounters I was just
in a festival
and some girls just assumed like after
three minutes that I was gay
so
I think it um the boys I have to really
pay attention to my voice
um looking um do some testosterone
levels checks and yeah I got some
homework to do like do a bit of a
makeover when it comes to your look as
well I don't know if you want to mess
around with the hair and the facial hair
and the style and all that but I mean if
you can but if you can get yourself into
like a more masculine frame sort of
thing you probably have less pushback
from the gals this is kind of difficult
for me right because I'm not a chick
um I know what women are attracted to
right and I mean it should be obvious to
them whether you're gay or straight like
most women they seem to know like right
away it's almost like women have gaydar
like gay guys have where they know if
somebody's gay or straight so you're
sending off some Vibes that they're
picking up on that they're going hang on
a sec this guy looks like he could be
gay right
yeah yeah I just saw my hair too I just
started growing it I I like to
experiment I like to have adventures and
um
so uh I'm pretty okay
have you ever said to you Alberto you
look like so and so
yeah yeah definitely I like rock and
roll and uh usually it's somebody
um from that area is there an artist or
somebody that they say that you look
like
definitely yeah I got many yeah
yeah also I get a lot um for in Mexico I
get they tell me they ask me if I'm from
uh uh Arabia like Qatar in those places
no I can tell by your accent that you're
Latin but yeah you do look kind of like
maybe you're from the Middle East too so
the reason why I'm asking is is because
like women have said to me throughout
the years like Rich you know you look
like the rock you look like Vin Diesel
you look like Triple H uh the WWE guy
you look like um
there's a few guys that I've passed off
that are like you know conventionally
masculine sort of dudes right so you
know we always say you want to have a
look
and you kind of want to own it sort of
thing so whenever somebody's like oh
reach your ball to say yeah that's part
of the look stupid don't you think I
shaved my head to have that look right
so I mean if you can find a strong
masculine figure that's prominent in
Hollywood or in you know certain circles
that the gals run in that you like and
then sort of mimic that look
then that'll give you a little bit of an
advantage because it'll be like oh
Alberto looks like whatever you know
yeah I get I get told that a lot thank
you for the advice I have one ask good
um I thought I think that I'm not too
I don't I don't chase girls a lot
um I don't think it's my time I'm I'm
waiting I'm really working on myself and
uh being successful and I see it as a
waste of time sometimes and I'm not sure
if that has something to do with the way
that I might well you have that I behave
in your intentions right like you have
to express interest in them rather than
sort of lollygagging around and thinking
well if I spent two or three nights with
her she'll hopefully want to bang me
right uh Alan Roger Curry died recently
he wrote a great book called mode one
and he talks about direct communication
methods when it comes to dealing with
women you might want to check it out
because it'll help you sort of like
calibrate yourself to a more direct
Conversation Piece with these gals
okay
all right will do okay man
um awesome thank you so much for the
advice all right buddy take care I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out